hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mad
father okay I'm back in the entrance
hall from which there were psalms armed
before but apparently not anymore I'm
now going to be exploring what the hell
is that okay oh we're off to a great
start now what is that what is that
lots of hard to read books cuz I'm just
a little girl little girl got an
archives keep good it's locked I don't
know the code unlock it well if you say
so sister what was you sent someone
okay right
being the saver that I am gonna
keep saving alright see what happened to
that little boy over here hello I'm here
to be Attic what was that what is that
why is it go blinky blinky is that
actually me blinking or what okay I
can't run like in no witch's house all
right okay what is that what's that in
the top right what is that I here's all
right do I hear
here's some scratching what is oh
there's a zombie down here
oh there's zom zoms down there Oh what
was that like ax
okay get the archive key so I'm gonna in
the archives I guess it's hard to read
books riddle encyclopedia scattered
books the flame egg aha I remember this
book this power or girl who has a
mysterious power to control fire and she
goes on journey to find a family she's
been separated from proclaiming burn all
zones in my way she did exactly that to
all her foes but didn't think of the end
her bauer got out of control and
destroyed the world that's pretty
horrific so she never met her family in
the end she was all alone poor girl all
alone hmm
is there an analogy there I don't want
it I don't want to be all alone I have
to say father quick no we're gonna take
this very patiently and slowly to make
sure that we don't miss anything
handwritten memo humans are beautiful
but that beauty soon fades that is the
law of this world but I have overturned
it after research years of research I
have found eternal Beauty a body that
will never fade even in death a body is
fresh when they were still alive they
have eternal beauty within their grasp
okie-dokie really concerned with beauty
all that much all right can't go that
way
see lots of hard to read books data on
live experimentation grody
I can't read this there's something
stuck in here dot code memo a code to a
safe alright give me I'm drooling all
over myself I wanna go home
I wanna see mama oh oh it's you creepy
lady I shall take you to her once this
is all over no I want to go mama mama
don't fret everything will be fine I
don't think I don't think it may hurt a
bit but not much
you'll soon feel such relief cuz you'll
be dead
okay Saab I don't wonder I didn't know I
had to press anything there you're still
here yeah punch it right in the face but
you're writing the freaking face okay I
didn't go down that way I wanted to go
see what's over there but you peepee
creepy it's locked
good good good okay so there's walking
corpses around everything that will lead
me to new memories that I don't want to
see anyway everything hi what where'd
you go where'd you go you were back here
where'd you go the doll room hey these
look familiar I remember these dolls
from mad father or witch's house yeah I
remember them for mad father seeing them
right now I remember that I've got a gem
yay they're both okay dolls have a
creepy smile no joke
are these dolls it's not a doll is it
it's not a doll okay can I pull back
these curtains okay all right I'm out of
here
Oh dolls are just another form of
mannequin that I do not enjoy hi hey
come back here I saw that what are you
doing I saw that okay - a learn today
Yeah right all right I'll just
she's doing some I gotta let it get
close I guess where to go it did
something damn it okay I'm gonna ignore
it yeah I don't think you're doing
anything I don't think it's actually
doing anything that I need to know
okay these zom zoms are still down here
but I can go in here alright well
maintain flower reception room not the
room filled with blood I don't trust
those paintings what I thought I heard
someone I did too
you heard it little girl hey I didn't
see that jiggle you want the ones you
love to be happy for this good LARM chug
all you need is one thing and this with
you is love kiss someone's forehead with
love and say a blessing and then they
will magically have good luck isn't that
wonderful
I have to kiss the picture it's eating
me oh okay
I'll fight for my life oh that's a
health bar up there push it harder I'm
pushing it as pushy as I can Jesus get
away from me I've lost half my health I
think okay and no apparently was not you
do not recall being mauled by a zombie
Amon yeah move the painting you feel a
draft with that giant hole in the
painting really okay
yeah we're outside let's go home and
never come back here I found another gem
I highly doubt that I'm gonna get all of
the gems just saying that right now I'm
obviously gonna miss some somewhere so
don't be upset with me if I miss some
gems on just full water
good okay anything else interesting here
okay they looked about it let's get out
of the air and never come back
save again saving and all that
jazz and move on to the room of blood my
oh the bathroom is it alive oh it was
just kept Turkey the hell is going on
boo why was that doll moving excellent
question little girl I don't know that
part of the girl I don't know dog get me
zom zoms cafeteria yay Yuki how
convenient
hello birdie Thank You mr. save oh I got
another job yay hooray good for me
what's that gobbling sound someone
eating my steak dinner oh what's that
what is that says Amba dog
I sincerely hope not got oil yay
goody is that another gem I'm getting
all the gems I should stay away
good good good move excellent move it's
pitch black you can't go down there why
not you big baby
don't do that to me stop it stop it stop
it okay we're gonna haha if that was LOX
that's gonna be in a lot of trouble
alright doing good
I've got law m's I don't know how many
but I got a lot pushing marks it's long
no no no don't do that oh my goodness
I don't know kid oh are you asking me
let's run straight into okay maybe not
what should I do
it's like in The Flaming burn all those
in my way yeah I can burn it boy how
nice a little kid I have a feeling that
all your stories have you read are kind
of coming to life here you know with the
red-eyed stranger and then the burning
things alive you're also kind of a
strange kid aren't you you're just a
little weird how about one of these
barrels I've got oil how do I use that
there's like an inventory oil
oh wait code memo wait what barrels in
first-floor East Hall chandeliers and
entrance hall red dolls and doll room
paintings in reception room okay I think
there were two paintings I don't know
how many barrels
okay so wait is this East this would be
the East Room I see seven barrels okay
and I need to read this again ah okay
seven barrels
okay last ones too so it's seven
something something too
one two three four anymore anymore
anymore okay so seven four I think seven
four one two three four five six seven
eight seven four eight two would be my
guess
seven four eight two seven four eight
two they couldn't make it easy you know
just give me the code they gotta make me
guess is it in here I think it was okay
but in the code yeah
7 4 8 - yeah I'm a genius
I'm so smart can tain mom's what it
smells like mom what was it there's a
lamp in here hey I can go down in the
basement with doggy laughter we are the
old prospector autos down ok sorry I
apologize I apologize sincerely for my
previous actions got the lamp love lamp
and gem this is what mom's perfume may
so flashback time okay that's what's
going on here is he still at work
Marya doctor
foie fat her her hey that's me they'll
save those things uh-huh there you are
to see your father always tell you not
to go into the basement MA
mom don't don't look no no don't look he
I knew it he's cheating on me with her I
can't believe this
some girl he picked up on the street I
won't forgive him not gonna confront him
it's probably for the best
pacing back and forth angrily ugh this
stupid thing what stupid thing off with
the ring ring perfume I don't know bride
the perfume
mom's usually so nice but she seems so
different then well yeah I would be
pissed too but is now really the time
for a flashback I put it back on her
dresser after that but she took care of
it that's good after all mom got this
from father on their anniversary so I'm
sure mom loved father to the very end
I'll take it as a charm yeah I'm pretty
sure that little ol Maria didn't kill
your mother anything or reiden do weird
stuff you know yeah
close the door it'd be very very polite
about these things okay all right
I'm right I am all out of time for now
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
the spiders from reaching your daughter
fighters I don't yeah
oh you think you can mess with me Oh
what